good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-1696
containment class ketter
disruption class vlam
and risk class warning
special containment procedures
containment of
scp-1696 is to be handled directly by
mobile task force zeta 29 blood brothers
scp-1696 is to be detained in a standard
humanoid containment chamber located at
site 19. on-site personnel are to
constantly monitor
scp-1696's chamber via video and audio
recording devices any changes in
behavior are to be immediately logged
scp-1696 is to be released from
containment whenever it desires
during an off-site excursion
scp-1696 is to be escorted directly to
its destination by mobile task force
zeta 29 using whatever mode of
transportation is most convenient a
secondary team are to move ahead of this
main escort group and preemptively dose
the target with a high-grade
tranquilizer so as to ensure
unconsciousness once
scp-1696 has successfully terminated the
civilian in question it is to be invited
back into containment
description
scp-1696 is an entity presumably
humanoid in shape the body of which is
perpetually concealed underneath a large
cotton sheet
due to the presence of this sheet a full
physical description of scp-1696
is not possible superficial analysis of
the entity however indicates that
scp-6096 is 1.55 meters tall and weighs
approximately 48 kilograms the sheath
covering
scp-1696 is larger than the actual body
and typically trails at least a meter
behind it when it is mobile personnel
have been unable to attempt to remove
this sheet in order to obtain a more
accurate description
no living being can consciously take an
action which would result in harm coming
to scp-1696
an action which would result in harm
coming to scp-1696 is a broad category
and has been observed to consist of acts
including attempting to attack scp-1696
attempting to order others to attack
scp-1696
attempting to trick others into
unknowingly attacking
scp-1696 attempting to lay a trap for
scp-1696
attempting to order others to lay a trap
for scp-1696
attempting to trick others into
unknowingly laying a trap for scp-1696
attempting to create a device which
would independently and automatically
cause harm to
scp-1696 attempting to leave
scp-1696's presence when doing so would
expose the entity to harm attempting to
self-terminate if said self-termination
would result in negative repercussions
for
scp-1696
and attempting to remove
scp-6096's bed sheet
scp-1696 is usually docile allowing
itself to be led into containment so
long as said relocation would not result
in harm coming to it at periodic
intervals however
scp-1696 will become active and
independently mobile persistently moving
at walking speeds towards a target
in all observed cases this target has
been a human being selected at random
from the population of the planet earth
any individual who observes scp-1696
during an active period will gain an
instant awareness of the identity of the
current target along with their location
additionally they will find themselves
compelled to aid scp-1696 in reaching
and securing its target
evidence suggests that
scp-1696's target alone is exempt from
its main anomalous property they are
able to take actions which would cause
harm to scp-1696
to date however none have been
successful in doing so usually due to
the unwilling efforts of the entourage
scp-1696 inevitably accumulates during
its journey to the target
when
scp-1696 physically reaches the target
it will subsume them underneath its
cotton sheet in cases where the victim
is conscious they can be seen and heard
struggling against
scp-1696 underneath the bed sheet for a
period ranging from 20 to 40 minutes
after which they will disappear entirely
the cries of distress emitted by these
victims suggest that this process is
extremely painful following acquisition
of its victim
scp-1696 will return to a docile state
addendum 1696 1 initial containment
scp-1696 first came to the attention of
the foundation on 09 12 2018 when the
police in the town of durham new mexico
were called to the home of the local
malian family the parents of the family
samuel and amanda melian claimed that
scp-6090 had entered their home and
caused their 16-year-old son desmond
malian to vanish
scp-1696 was still present at the home
when police arrived and when authorities
subsequently found themselves physically
unable to remove the sheet covering it
agents embedded in their regional
government alerted the foundation and
brought the entity into initial
containment
the household of the malian family was
equipped with several cameras for home
security purposes
and so the arrival of
scp-1696 was also captured on film the
following is a transcribed log of the
relevant portion of this footage
the malian family is sat on the couch in
their living room facing the television
samuel and amanda malian are actively
watching the television while desmond
malian is scrolling on his phone the
sound of a car pulling in can be heard
this is believed to be drake ellen a
local taxi driver dropping
scp-6096 off outside the house several
seconds later samuel malian nudges his
wife and points towards the out-of-shot
window
we're closer to christmas aren't we
it's
[Music]
amanda reaches over and grabs desmond's
arm tightly he looks up from his phone
what's up i'm doing stuff
nothing i mean just
well just stay there okay
just stay with me
scp-1696 is barely audible as it gently
knocks on the front door
samuel shakily gets up from the couch
and moves over to the front door he
opens it anna cp 1696 enters
the hell
is that kimmy
what you all dressed up for
hey could you let me go you you're kind
of hurting me that's funny honey
i'm sorry honey it's just don't move and
it'll be fine
i always hurt your arm when you're
trying to pull away that's just
as
scp-1696 approaches samuel moves ahead
of it and grabs desmond's other arm
holding him down against the couch
that's just fine
just stay still honey
you just close your eyes it won't hurt
you if you do close your eyes
i love you
desmond attempts to break free but he's
unable he kicks his legs wildly in the
air his phone slips off the arm of the
couch and falls onto the carpet
i'm serious
my [ __ ] arm
scp-6096 reaches desmond and begins to
subsume him feet first under the cotton
sheet amanda and samuel watch mouths
open as desmond is fully dragged under
the sheet visibly struggling it appears
that they are attempting to scream but
are unable
desmond begins to loudly scream and
violent thrashing can be seen onto the
sheet
this continues for 36 minutes
once desmond has completely vanished
scp-1696 returns to a docile state it
wraps itself in the cotton sheet and
sits down on the carpet facing the
television
samuel collapses to the floor and curls
up into the fetal position seemingly in
a state of shock hermandez staggers
backwards to the far wall continuing to
face
scp-1696 and calls emergency services on
her cell phone
all parties remain in the same positions
save for samuel's occasional rocking
until police arrive
end log
all immediate witnesses were dosed with
a class a amnestic and a cover story for
the disappearance of desmond malion was
produced it is currently unknown how
long
scp-1696 was operating prior to this
event if at all
addendum
1696 two
welcome notice
and there you have it
welcome to mobile task forces 29.
the booze is under the sink
no need to worry about professionalism
down here the higher-ups couldn't demo
me if they wanted to apparently my
presence says head of scp-1696
containment is beneficial enough to it
that me being reassigned would count as
harming it
lucky me
you're probably wondering how he can be
shameless enough to say that we have
this thing under containment it comes
and goes whenever it feels like it and
if it ever decided it didn't want to
come back to its containment cell we
literally have no way of enforcing it
and yeah you're probably also thinking
that calling a roommate containment
chamber instead of a hotel room is just
as shameful
to that i say
you're absolutely right
there's nothing we can do against
scp-1690
feel free to take a drink until you're
able to accept that
don't hold back
you're gonna become very familiar with
that bottle anyway
i know i did the first time i had to
hold the door to a maternity ward hoping
for this thing
the idea of containing
scp-1696 is a bad joke we all decided a
long time ago that the only way out of
this nightmare is liquidation
decommissioning neutralization whatever
you want to call it but that's no walk
in the park either i've stood in that
chamber for hours gun pointed at 1696's
head screaming at my finger just to
tighten slightly
didn't work
you can't harm scp-1696 no matter how
much you want to you can't even try to
start a rube goldberg kind of thing to
eventually
harm
scp-1696 it's it's just a fact of the
world
maybe a semi-ope semi-hazard or whatever
it's called
the way i see it there are three main
ways out of this nightmare
another organization maybe the goc takes
a shot at it without realizing what
they're dealing with maybe they're
thinking we're transporting something
more dangerous maybe they think we're in
over our heads with it and they take it
out with a drone or something blow the
thing to hell while we're transporting
it the bomb would kill it easy i think
it feels weak this would only work so
long as the glc thinks they're bombing
something else entirely if they knew it
was scp-1696
they'd just be contained two
next an aic deals with it
i don't know if an artificial
intelligence is immune to
scp-1696's effects but the fact that it
won't let me tell one of them about it
gives me hope maybe one day one of those
computers gets a mission and maybe that
mission by complete coincidence happens
to lead them over to this file then they
use their superior intelligence to set
things up so 1696 runs into an accident
out of the blue
and finally
a target gets lucky
maybe 1696 goes after a gun nut and the
poor guy gets a lucky shot in before we
can hold him down
this almost happened once but lopez took
the bullet poor guy bled out while we
were holding the target down for 1696.
maybe it'll happen again
go better
maybe maybe
maybe
let's be honest these scenarios
aren't scenarios they're fantasies
the odds of any of these things
happening on their own are tiny
minuscule the only thing that can really
do 1696 in as far as i can see is sheer
coincidence
in the end all we can do is wait and
hope hope for one of us to make a
genuine mistake that gets the right
dominoes falling
but that wouldn't hold your breath
after all
we're [ __ ] good at what we do
charlie szymanski commander of mobile
task force aided 29 blood brothers
signing out
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargeron
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
nicholas hayes
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
jaby
pure osmium
sayo diodemnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbidge
longinus
carcass death aqua
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you